first of all we are just doing money at
this at the problem we're throwing
resources at the problem it costs money
but we don't just hand out cash to
people we're going in there doing
specific interventions one of them is to
improve the farming methods and the
agricultural techniques to increase the
yield of the farmers another is to
prevent malaria by using bed nets and to
fight malaria with a 80 sent cure that
anybody in the in the Western world
could afford but it doesn't get to a lot
of these folks in the developed
developing world and so we see that
millions of people are dying every year
due to malaria and we know that cripples
those communities and we know that if
you do a lot of other interventions is
not going to work if everyone's still
dying and people aren't healthy enough
to work and so we figured that providing
malaria prevention and cure for malaria
was important also providing ARVs for
AIDS sufferers to allow them to live a
meaningful life and live a longer life
that many people in the Western world
with HIV and AIDS are able to live we
figured that was important we also
believe that getting them access to
clean drinking water is important and
getting young people into schools and
getting them a meal during school is
important so we're not throwing money at
the problem we're throwing we're
spending money to bring solutions to the
problems we're not just throwing cash at
it and I think that's important but I
also believe that what mr. Eunice is
doing is really important too and i
think is working as well and i don't
think there's any one cure all solution
to poverty but i think what their needs
to be as a commitment which I don't
think for instance our US government has
shown a commitment to it and then once
you have the commitment and you really
believe that it's important defining
defining problem
and a problem that is is one of the more
critical issues of our time once you
believe that then reasonable Minds can
try different techniques to solve the
problem but at least you have to admit
that it's a major problem and decide
that you have to throw a lot of
resources at it it's not going to just
go away and I believe that Jeffrey Sachs
believes that and that's why we're
working again